y
[Música]
en ucrania volodymyr selenski visito
mykolaiv es la primera visita del
presidente a esta ciudad del sur del
país desde que empezó la guerra el
desplazamiento llega después de que este
viernes un ataque ruso matar a dos
personas e hiriera otras veinte tenemos
reporte desde ucrania
en ecuador el ejecutivo de guillermo
lasso decretó el estado de excepción en
tres regiones del país una respuesta a
las masivas protestas indígenas y
bloqueos en las vías en rechazo al alto
costo de la vida y en reclamo de más
justicia social
a un día de la segunda vuelta
presidencial el panorama electoral en
colombia nunca fue tan incierto el país
votará entre el populista rodolf
hernández y el izquierdista gustavo
petro pero sea quien sea que llegue a la
presidencia cargará con el legado de
iván duque como parte de nuestra serie
especial sobre las elecciones les
traemos el balance del gobierno saliente
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 soy rosa pérez masdéu y es
para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos con información en europa
porque en ucrania volodymyr selenski
visito mykolaiv es el primer
desplazamiento del mandatario a esta
ciudad del país desde el inicio de la
guerra la visita llega después de que
este viernes un ataque ruso matar a dos
personas e hiriera otras 20 en esta
localidad por otro lado en el este del
país continúa siendo el campo de batalla
decisivo para el transcurso de la guerra
nuestra enviada especial leticia álvarez
con la actualización de la situación
desde jarquín
hoy el presidente hace lens que ha
visitado la ciudad de nikolai e
fuertemente bombardeada en las últimas
semanas y que hace frontera con gerson
una zona ocupada por el ejército ruso y
donde ahora las tropas ucranianas
intentan recuperar territorio la guerra
en este país continúa con ataques con
misiles
aquí friv una zona de donde es
originario el propio presidente
ucraniano pero donde se está
concentrando la intensidad de todos los
ataques es en la batalla del donbass
está siendo crucial según información de
inteligencia
internacional las tropas rusas estarían
moviendo artillería y batallones de la
zona donde nos encontramos en kharkiv
hacia el donbass hacia esa batalla que
se está librando en sever donés y
lysychansk es muy importante esta
batalla y lo ha dicho el propio
negociador ucraniano porque según sus
palabras están dispuestos a negociar
después de que pase el verano cuando
vuelvan a retomar las posiciones que
tenía este país antes de que empezara la
invasión rusa lo cierto es que sobre el
terreno rusia está avanzando muy
y vamos ahora con información de nuestra
región porque tres regiones de ecuador
despertaron bajo estado de excepción la
noche de este viernes el ejecutivo de
hielo de guillermo lasso decretó la
medida en respuesta a las protestas y a
los bloqueos de varias vías del país el
descontento ciudadano estalló en medio
del aumento de los costes de vida y por
lo tanto de las desigualdades el informe
es de rafael pérez me comprometo a
defender nuestra capital y a defender el
país esto me obliga a declarar el estado
de excepción en pichincha imbabura y
cotopaxi a partir de la medianoche de
hoy de esta forma el presidente de
ecuador guillermo lasso trata de
apaciguar los ánimos tras más de cinco
días de protestas indígenas el estado de
excepción tendrá 30 días de duración en
los que se movilizarán a las fuerzas
armadas se suspenden los derechos de
asociación y reunión además de la
imposición de un toque de queda nocturno
en quito la capital
laso dio a conocer además otras
disposiciones para frenar descontento
social tales como el incremento del
valor del bono de desarrollo humano de
50 a 55 dólares la condonación de
créditos vencidos de hasta tres mil
dólares en el banco estatal de
desarrollo el subsidio a los medianos
agricultores de la mitad del costo de
lahore a un fertilizante necesario para
la producción y la congelación del
precio de las gasolinas una de las
principales demandas de los
manifestantes
asimismo el mandatario hizo un llamado
al diálogo convocando a todos los
sectores de la sociedad el líder de las
movilizaciones leonidas iza saludó las
medidas económicas anunciadas desde el
palacio de carondelet pero enfatizó que
las movilizaciones continuarían
ratificamos la lucha a nivel nacional
ratificamos la lucha de manera
indefinida y ratificamos la lucha en
este caso a nivel territorial pero
también desde este momento preparamos la
movilización en la ciudad de equipo las
protestas en ecuador comenzaron el
pasado lunes con el cierre de las
carreteras por parte de la confederación
indígena a la que se han ido sumando
otras organizaciones
en chile se cumplen los primeros 100
días del gobierno de gabriel boric el
estado de emergencia en la macro zona
sur las repercusiones del aumento global
de los precios o las discusiones sobre
la nueva constitución han opacado parte
de la agenda del presidente sin embargo
destacan la firma del acuerdo de escazú
en temas medioambientales la condonación
de la deuda estudiantil o la subida del
salario mínimo entre sus medidas más
populares
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en santiago patricia luna
quien nos contó cuáles son las críticas
de la oposición a estos 100 días de
mandato
las críticas críticas si giran en torno
a los temas que ya hemos imaginado
especialmente al hecho de que el
gobierno de gabriel boris afirman no se
hace cargo del tema de la delincuencia
no actúa con la suficiente contundencia
en las calles también muchas críticas en
torno al decretado estado de excepción
en la araucanía en el sur es ha sido
decretado un estado de excepción acotado
es decir que sólo se establece para
regular por ejemplo la para que la
policía y las fuerzas armadas regulen el
tráfico pero no tengan otro tipo de
intervenciones borica había sido
contrario tradicionalmente durante la
campaña a decretar un estado de
excepción en el sur para la oposición el
gobierno no tiene una agenda marcada en
torno a los temas de seguridad que están
afectando mucho a los ciudadanos también
críticas en torno a la subida de los
precios y las medidas que está tomando
el gobierno al respecto y por supuesto
también qué ocurre si en el previsto de
salida previsto para el próximo 4 de
septiembre gana la opción del rechazo
eso también ha marcado como también
señala vais mucho la agenda
al empezar a evaluar qué ocurriría así
como dicen las encuestas se impone el
rechazo a una nueva constitución el 4 de
septiembre
y continuamos con información de nuestro
continente porque colombia entró en la
recta final con miras a la segunda
vuelta presidencial este domingo 39
millones de colombianos elegirán a su
nuevo presidente entre el populista
rodolfo hernández y el izquierdista
gustavo petro los ciudadanos irán a las
urnas sin antes haber presenciado un
debate de propuestas entre ambos
candidatos además de inédito el panorama
de cara a las elecciones de este domingo
es extremadamente incierto pero sea
quien sea que llegue a la presidencia
recibirá el legado del gobierno de iván
duque como parte de nuestra serie
especial sobre los comicios colombianos
les traemos este balance del mandato de
iván duque que terminara oficialmente el
7 de agosto
el 7 de agosto iván duque entrega las
llaves del palacio de nariño así fueron
los eventos clave que marcaron su
mandato tras poco más de un año de
llegar a la presidencia duque hizo
frente a su primera gran crisis las
masivas protestas de noviembre de 2019
un indicio de lo que sería el estallido
social de abril de 2021 derivando las
mayores manifestaciones en la historia
reciente de colombia la respuesta del
gobierno una fuerte represión
5 mil 340 casos de violencia perpetrados
por la fuerza pública 40 homicidios y 35
casos de violencia sexual fue lo que
vimos durante tres meses una respuesta
al gobierno muy violenta una
criminalización de la protesta social
cuatro años en donde la violencia se
expresó con muchas caras unas derivadas
de las falencias en la implementación de
los acuerdos de paz 223 masacres sólo
entre 2020 y 2022 cerca de medio millón
de desplazados desde 2018 y más de 850
líderes sociales asesinados durante el
actual mandato según indepaz
precisamente por la no implementación
del actual 2 paz comenzó a
recomponerse
la violencia dinámica de grupos armados
atentados contra líderes el covent 19
asecho al país dejando 275 personas
fallecidas por cada 100.000 habitantes
la quinta tasa de mortalidad de la
región pero con un plan de vacunación
parcialmente exitoso 70% de la población
está totalmente inoculada la pandemia
también le marcó el pulso a la economía
del país y puso a prueba la respuesta
del gobierno muy bueno lo que pasó en
términos de la respuesta y las medidas
de política económica frente a la crisis
no tan bueno diría yo decepcionante lo
que pasó en términos de la expectativa
que iba a ser un gobierno reformista y
que iba a ser digamos una serie de
medidas para continuar impulsando el
crecimiento económico y la equidad la
frontera con venezuela otra protagonista
más de un millón de personas entraron a
colombia desde 2018 una afluencia masiva
hacia un país lejos de estar preparado
pero la respuesta del gobierno fue uno
de sus logros
yo quisiera destacar de este gobierno la
continuidad que se le dio al manejo del
tema migratoria que sin duda es una de
las políticas tal vez más ambiciosas en
materia de atención social a una
población con bastante necesidad lo que
transita la recta final de su mandato
cargada de obstáculos un paro armado a
manos del grupo criminal plan del golfo
que afectó a 11 de los 32 departamentos
del país y un índice de desaprobación
que ronda el 65 por ciento
y recuerden que los invitamos este
domingo a conectarse con el especial que
tenemos preparado aquí en france 24 para
la segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
colombianas andrés meza los estará
acompañando con el análisis de nuestros
invitados y periodistas en el lugar de
la noticia
y vamos ahora a europa porque el sur del
continente atraviesa una ola de calor
impropia para esta época del año se
trata de una de las consecuencias
anunciadas del cambio climático que
podría convertirse en la norma ante la
falta de contundencia de las políticas
climáticas a nivel global la situación
en el sur de francia en el siguiente
informe
para combatir el calor esta escuela de
la región occidental del país de la luz
está en alerta máxima los sombreros son
obligatorios y las actividades diarias
se han modificado para evitar la
insolación los profesores rocían a los
niños con agua y se aseguran de que se
mantengan alejados del sol
[Música]
busquets
así calma
muchos padres optaron por dejar a sus
hijos en casa o vinieron a recogerlos al
mediodía
esta mañana fueron a la escuela el calor
aún era manejable pero esta tarde
organizado las cosas con el trabajo para
poder quedarme en casa y ellos también
están aquí si las temperaturas han
superado la barrera de los 40 grados en
algunas zonas de francia al menos 13
zonas registraron las temperaturas más
altas de la historia para esta época del
año en antibes ciudad costera de la
costa azul hace más que calor
vivimos en el campo y los depósitos de
agua están empezando a secarse esto no
suele ocurrir nunca y es preocupante
casi nadie sale a la calle y la mayoría
de personas han cerrado sus casas pero
algunos no pueden permitirse el lujo de
quedarse en casa como estos trabajadores
que cuidan los jardines públicos en
toulouse
hay que tener cuidado de no excederse
uno se puede marear muy fácilmente
hay que tener cuidado tengo varios
colegas que se enfermaron hace tanto
calor que vomitaron y algunos se
desmayaron
este mensajero en bicicleta decidió irse
a casa por el día
me voy a casa porque ahora es difícil ir
en bicicleta es la ola de calor más
temprana registrada en francia desde
1947 las temperaturas siguen subiendo y
deberían alcanzar su punto máximo el
sábado antes de que empiecen a bajar
según las previsiones a partir del
domingo
y vamos ahora a bangladesh porque 25
personas han perdido la vida por las
fuertes lluvias que azotan el país las
autoridades señalaron que la emergencia
deja además más de cuatro millones de
personas aisladas debido a los
deslizamientos de tierra según
previsiones meteorológicas las
inundaciones se podrían agravar en los
próximos días
y volvemos a cambiar de tema porque el
ejército israelí volvió a bombardear la
franja de gaza- esta noche atacando
objetivos de hamas según israel el
ataque responde al lanzamiento de
cohetes no reivindicados que fueron
interceptados por el sistema antimisiles
cúpula de hierro la ofensiva aérea en
gaza- se encadena con la represión de la
población palestina en jerusalén y
cisjordania
y cerramos a recordando el cumpleaños de
uno de los iconos más grandes de la
historia de la cultura popular se trata
de paul mccartney el ex beatle cumple
este sábado 80 años y la celebración ha
sido en los escenarios el octagenario
músico fue sorprendido el pasado jueves
por sus fanáticos durante uno de sus
conciertos en nueva york allí cerca de
60.000 espectadores corearon feliz
cumpleaños a la leyenda del pop
británico
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]